you like farts
um do I like them I mean are you cool
okay how do you feel about that in
relationships open farting
um
I I don't know I don't I don't think I
I don't know I think it would kind of I
don't know yeah no I don't I don't like
it yeah because it makes it more
attractive yeah no like you hide that
[__] yeah but if an occasional like
blast comes from the office that's kind
of funny but like just keep it out of
the bedroom keep it out you know I don't
want to roll you into an enchilada and
like blast you know I'm not gonna live
in a place yeah I just think that you
know I'm not I don't ever I don't like
sharing that stuff no you're uh you're a
close the door leave me alone uh
uh yeah did you disappear you're one of
those women who disappear and like
where'd they go they must be pooping in
the third bathroom on the third floor
right no but we talk about this a lot on
Broad ideas it's like when you go away
on a trip with someone for the first
time right
how are you gonna how is that gonna work
out that's the biggest concern Where Are
You Gonna [__] I know what you do what
do you do here's what I would do what
would you do
I'd probably say hey the pool looks
really sweet why don't you head out to
the pool I gotta take care of a few
things interesting or you say hey I'm
gonna go check with the front desk I'll
be back I want to see if they have any
massages and then
pow
and then you know come back and go
you're like what about the massages like
oh they weren't there and just
what if they want to go with you see
that no no no no no you stay you you
stay there I want to take care of this I
want to surprise you well it's not a
surprise anymore you already told me I
know but I just wanted something I have
to do on my own
hahaha
thing man it's a thing